Welcome back, this week we're teaching the horses to receive a reward in the
form of a pet. So we're using the exercise of using an obstacle or a jump,
a cavaletti or a pole, having the horse go over the poles or cavalettis and then
stopping and giving them a pat. In this example here I've got three cavalettis
set on nine feet apart so that we can do this in walk, trot and canter. In this
particular horse's demonstration we'll do it in the walk and the trot. So as you
can see the start is to lead him over the cavalettis and show him exactly how
to go over the cavalettis and then when I stop my feet he must stop his feet and
you see me there correcting him exactly where I stopped he needs to stop. After
that point he gets a pet. So they should be so in tune that they could stop at
any time and they're comfortable being over top of the pole and clearing the
pole and knowing exactly where it is. So you see there this horse actually really
likes being scratched so I'm adding that to the reward, a pet on the forehead, a
little scratch on the neck. If your horse doesn't like being scratched avoid that.
So watch out for things and be aware of some things, how accurate is your
horse at knowing their own body and being able to manipulate it over the
obstacles. This tells you a lot about how your horse learns and how they move
their body and how they receive information from obstacles and outside
sources.
So the next stage is to have them go over the obstacles alone without your
lead and you see here he's very comfortable doing that and he can stop
when I stop. If your horse is nervous they're gonna want to come towards you
and not do it on their own, simply encourage them to step away from you and
do the obstacle or solve the problem on their own. Remember every groundwork
exercise we do, every exercise we do with the horses is to direct the horse to
control himself, not so that we can control the horses. The more the horse is
confident with his own self-control the more confident he will be with the task
that we give him. Good, so now we've moved on to encouraging the trot. You can tell
this horse is not paying attention so I'm having to give him reminders on how
to pay attention, come in and get his reward. So if your horse is slightly
distracted like this one you may have to indicate to them exactly where they
should be, whether they should be solving the problem, coming for the reward or
simply resting. So you see I'm giving him the little trot steps with my feet to
encourage him to trot and then I'm also having to remind him how to halt
because his attention level is low. If your horse is more sensitive you're
gonna want to be very very light and effective with your voice, your body
commands and make sure that you're not misfiring any commands towards them so
that they stay light and sensitive to your aids.
When repeating this exercise repeat it until it's so boring for the horses,
repeat it until they could do it in their sleep, do it so many times and
recognize the equality of doing it both left and right exactly the same, exactly
the same amount of times and there's gonna be a harder side for the horse. You
might have to practice that a little bit more but recognize that you want to make
it even in the end. Here we have another example of a horse that's very confident
with their ability to maneuver their own body. This is a young horse still the same
age but this horse is more confident, more aware of their body so we can use
this same concept over a larger jump like this little barrel here that's
about two feet high. So he's already at the stage where he can jump it on his
own. Same as the other horse, this one needs a reminder to pay attention and
make sure that he's on task in the moment that he needs to be doing what he
needs to be doing. So jumping, he's jumping, coming back and getting a pet,
he's coming back and getting a pet. You see this horse is distracted by maybe
the other areas of the arena. Do your best to ignore that part and keep focused
on the task that you're asking him to do and the horses will respond by paying
attention to that task as well.